the most important thing a man can take
into combat it's a reason why being this
fight boys you mark my words
19 men attacked our country the 12 of
you will be the first ones to fight back
it's us we're going in you know I love
you right
I would be remiss if I did not say to
you even in success the odds of you
coming home very hard to appreciate sir
we're coming
[Music]
why these men follow you take me to the
Taliban I'll show you okay we take
horses he's serious
all right who's ridden before anyone
can't kill Spring Break ghost pretty
hey this is we [ __ ]
[Music]
50,000 okay to apply tears in your chest
an army of 12
we've just been handed the most
important mission in the free world
hold on our boys are gonna ride into
battle on horseback chances are we are
not gonna make it out of this one we
quit now what happened back home it's
gonna happen again and again
each you got to make this decision
nothing I'd rather do
oh man thought you'd never ask
[Music]
where the hell do those come from
take out biggest guns first I have a big
gun cap the only way home is waiting
this is from the towers you carry that
with you
you